et avec nous pour en parler jonas à
d'adorateurs de valérie pécresse
candidate de l air à la présidentielle
2022 bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés en direct par skype france 4
boeuf délégué départemental du modem
dans le nord bonsoir france 4 boeuf et
merci également d'être avec nous en
direct on évoquera en tout à l'heure
l'un des autres grands titres de
l'actualité en cette grève de jeudi à
l'école qui s'annonce massive pour
exprimer le ras-le-bol concernant le
protocole sanitaire mais d'abord on
s'arrête sur ses voeux des manuels
maquereau à la presse un haut début de
ce rendez-vous d'ailleurs le président
de l'association de la presse 1
présidentielle lui a lancé cette petite
phrase un peu taquine dans une
démocratie moderne on tient des
conférences de presse c'est vrai que au
début de son mandat emmanuel macron ne
voulait pas vraiment obtenir ce genre de
rendez-vous où il était en campagne il
s'agissait de se rabibocher avec les
journalistes prendre ce pas trop baffe
ou je ne perçois pas sous cet angle j'ai
plutôt l'impression que la situation
actuelle est trop difficile compliqué
tendu mouvante un cadre institutionnel
comme il l'a dit d'ailleurs peut
s'avérer utile parce que un peu de
solennité un peu de sérieux dans une
époque où tout le monde dit un peu
n'importe quoi sur n'importe quel
support ne peut pas être être critique
et donc je pense que je pense qu'il a
raison de s'institutionnaliser parce que
cela on oublie la fonction nas haddad
j'ai écouté avec attention ce que dit
l'intervenant précédent et ce qu'a dit
le président macron depuis des mois
c'est la personne qui fait des tic toc
envie en tee shirt pendant l'été c'est
la personne qui dit qu'ils emmerdent les
personnes qui sont non vaccinés donc
pour le cadre institutionnel on
repassera je pense simplement que
monsieur mâcon et la raison d'un point
de vue stratégique en tout cas ils
essayent de jouir à la fois de la
position de président et de la position
de candidat mais ce
ce double sa double casquette elle va
pas tenir très longtemps d'ailleurs le
président des républicains christian
jacob a demandé des comptes dès
aujourd'hui sur les déplacements du chef
de l'état parce qu'on voit bien qu'il
est en campagne il fait des chèques à
tout le monde il s'adresse à tout le
monde comme s'il était en campagne et
pourtant rien n'est comptabilisé donc un
moment je comprends ce que vous dites
sur le cadre institutionnel mais s'il ya
bien une personne qui a cassé les codes
de la communication présidentielle on
l'a vu lors de la fête de la musique à
l'elysée je le rappelle avec des images
qui nous marquent encore on l'a vu
lorsqu'il était à saint martin avec ces
délinquants qui faisaient des doigts
d'honneur je pense que si on a bien un
qui était pas dans le cadre classique
c'était bien emmanuel macron france quoi
trop bas vous comprenez tout de même que
ça
agace un petit peu les amis républicains
ils ont peut-être plus de mal à afficher
leur leur candidate d'ailleurs comme
tous les autres candidats alors qu
emmanuel macron lui se paye peut-être
une une tribune de luxe en ce moment
alors qu'il n'est pas encore déclaré
officiellement candidat alors que tout
le monde sait qu'il va se représenter il
n'y a pas une concurrence déloyale
vous savez la vie politique c'est un
éternel recommencement
moi je me suis engagé au modem contre
casse toi pauvre con et nicolas sarkozy
et copé contre l' emmerder les citoyens
alors eh bien
et à chacun de porter sa croix à tour de
rôle voilà alors nous centristes c'est
vrai que préférons une politique
artistique incontestable sommes
minoritaires priant sorte les énervés de
gauche et les intervet droite c'est vrai
alors le président de la république peut
être soupçonnée de faire campagne à la
fin antar comme avant lui françois
hollande bien qu'il ait renoncé à se
représenter comme avant françois
mitterrand comme avant lui nicolas
sarkozy comme tous les autres voilà gros
à écouter chez tous et comme cela on
peut être d'accord on peut le critiquer
mais le prochain président sera la même
chose enfin si si comme nous le
souhaitons emmanuel macron est réélu la
question ne se posera pas dans cinq ans
et nous aurons des candidats tout neuf a
présenté
suffrages des fonds de ce alors au cours
de ses voeux en tout cas en revenons à
ses voeux à la presse emmanuel macron
c'était le sujet a parlé d' évolution du
métier de journaliste et de ses dangers
il a d'ailleurs lancé cet avertissement
écouter
le métier de journaliste est bouleversée
partout y compris dans de grandes
démocraties par une conjonction aussi
inédite de phénomène
le modèle économique de votre profession
d'abord est battue en brèche par
l'avènement de grandes plateformes de
l'internet et de la société du tout
gratuit vous l'avez parfaitement dit je
reviendrai sur plusieurs
points que vous avez mentionné la
révolution numérique ensuite change
profondément la production même de
l'information
là où elle est et le monopole de
personnes formées pour cela aujourd'hui
chacun smartphone à la main ou clavier
au bout des doigts peut s'improviser et
je pèse mes mots journalistes comme le
dit un de vos confrères la presse de
plus en plus c'est donc devenu je le
cite entre guillemets un combat de rue
et janna sadate en sorte le président a
distribué un petit peu les bons points
et les mauvais points certains médias
d'ailleurs comme france 4 qui l'a
comparé une salle de classe géante
pendant le le premier confinement
il faut vivre avec son temps et faire
avec et ne pas forcément dénigrer où il
est dans son rôle et il a finalement
raison avec ce type de discours non là
dessus vous voyez comme quoi on n'est
pas des opposants énervé comme le disait
notre intervenant précédent moi je
partage totalement le constat des
maillots macron aujourd'hui tout le
monde s'improvise journalistes des gens
s'improvisent aussi influenceurs et
selon mots de michel denisot une
influence que les influençable et
effectivement il ya de plus en plus de
personnes qui croient des théories qui
sont ridicules véhiculées par des gens
simplement aux pros motifs qui l'ont
beaucoup d'abonnés et donc c'est le rôle
là pour le coup d'un présent la
république que je trouve que c'est bien
qu'il y ait eu une réflexion autour de
ça de s'intéresser à ces nouveaux
modèles parce que sinon effectivement ce
sera des théories qui seront pernicieuse
qui auront d'ailleurs un impact sur la
démocratie parce que c'est effectivement
en voyant des fausses rumeurs envoyant
des fausses informations que les gens
vont se sid est de plus en plus
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que au sein de
l'équipe de campagne de valérie pécresse
on s'occupe d'une cellule qui s'appelle
la cellule riposte on voit des fausses
informations qui sont véhiculées par
tous les candidats et c'est notre
responsabilité en tant à la fois que
responsable politique mais aussi de
journalistes de faire en sorte que le
choix des citoyens soit un choix éclairé
françois roboth et la raison de
s'inquiéter emmanuel macron ça va être
l'un des grands dangers
le grand danger
22 mais en réalité ce qu'il demande
c'est de fait rentrer l'ensemble des
acteurs de la formation dans le cadre
législatif de la loi de 1881 il n'y a
pas de droits sans devoirs c'est à dire
que tout le monde peut s'exprimer
librement mais à condition de respecter
le cadre de 180 tas n'est pas du tout
une atteinte à la liberté d'expression
c'est simplement responsabiliser vous
êtes journaliste vous c'est votre métier
vous êtes responsable et y est normal
que toutes celles et tous ceux qui
portent une information soit responsable
de la même manière en fait c'est tout
simple et ne puissent pas acheter de
quoi sous l'anonymat et donc
effectivement cette campagne vous avez
toutes les campagnes sont difficiles
bien sûr qu'elle sera qu'elle sera
brutal comme toutes les autres campagnes
mais est ce qui est important c'est de
travailler dans la durée c'est à dire
que vous savez la campagne dans six mois
les terminer et donc c'est ce qui est
important c'est que nous puissions avoir
un cadre institutionnel durable parce
qu'on sait bien que les chaînes de
télévision traditionnelles vont aller en
déclinant et il faut faire rentrer dans
ce cadre de responsabilité l'ensemble
des intervenants de l'information
publique comme privée c'est tout simple
et c'est tout à fait
je serais ravi france 80 que vous nous
qualifiez de journalistes parce que on
va essayer de prendre à nouveau le
président a parlé de la naïveté un jeu
c'est de la france de laisser on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure un les jeux cités
puissances étrangères
sont un petit peu visé faire leur
propagande comme des journalistes qui
sous-entendrait qu'on ne l'ait pas
vraiment je précise au président de la
république que nous avons une carte de
presse et qu'on
applique notre métier qu'on exerce notre
métier le plus honnêtement possible je
tenais à le préciser et ça serait
d'ailleurs aux journalistes entre eux de
faire le tri entre les médias fiable ou
non on va écouter emmanuel macron
nous ne sommes pas naïfs il ne s'agit
pas que de qualité de l'information il
s'agit aussi de savoir nous protéger là
aussi contre des ingérences de
puissances étrangères dans les
intentions sont très clairs et qu'ils
profitent de la pleine liberté que le
relais sont alors même souvent que ces
deux mêmes puissances vous empêche de
diffuser ou d'exercer votre profession
sur leur territoire
commence à se développer à cet égard les
processus d'autorégulation de
certification qui sont portées par vous
même par vos représentants pour
travailler avec les rédactions avec les
journalistes pour aider les citoyens les
acteurs privés les plateformes les
annonceurs des acteurs publics
les régulateurs aussi et pour identifier
les média fiable
fiable parce que le processus de
production de l'information répond à des
critères déontologiques de base
j'en ai et ce qu'ils soient contrôle qui
identifie les média fiable c'est une
bonne solution
alors toute profession un organisme de
régulation donc ça on peut pas contester
le fait que ce soit nécessaire mais
c'est assez curieux de voir ça de la
part d'un président qui a enregistré une
émission quelques jours à l'avance
contrôler et sur la première chaîne de
télé en france ces terres qui s'est payé
un spot publicitaire en réalité un et ça
me rappel vous savez dans ce film oss
117 dans lequel le français vient donner
des leçons aux étrangers en disant vous
êtes une dictature et puis après on lui
dit mais vous êtes vous même avec un
militaire à la tête de l'état et une
télévision qui est contrôlée qui était
le rtf de l'époque ait dit oui mais
c'est la france du général de gaulle bas
c'est un peu ça la france d' emmanuel
macron c'est qu'effectivement parfois
emmanuel macron il utilise à plein les
bleus vielles de son pouvoir
présidentiel pour contrôler et pour
avoir un message qui est très contrôlée
à son avantage et d'un autre côté ils
regrettent des ingérences de puissance
étrangère je pense que chaque
profession doit voir sa régulation et
même pour ceux que ça pour votre chaîne
pour les chaînes étrangères je pense que
c'est ça
existe donc je pense que ça c'est
légitime et personne ne peut y échapper
et d'ailleurs même s'il ya des critiques
qui sont formulées à l'encontre de
chaînes qui sont d'origine étrangère il
faut les entendre mais
venant de la bouche de quelqu'un qui a
un vrai contrôle de son image politique
et qui jouit de tous les leviers en tant
que président de la république c'est
assez cocasse à france 3 3 baffes
et
les mobilités en tout cas de vous
exprimer sur sur notre chaîne mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya deux poids deux mesures
emmanuel macron aurait peur quand elle
donne de la contradiction selon vous
mais vous savez ça me fait penser à
cette phrase de françois mitterrand
l'auteur de ce magnifique pamphlet coup
d'état permanent qui disait la vème
république était dangereuse avant moi
elle le sera de nouveau après mois
rappelons-nous mon contradicteur et est
l'héritier d'alain peyrefitte de son
mouvement politique lorsqu'alain père
suite été ministre de l'information le
contenu du journal de 20h se décider
dans son bureau et donc nous sommes
aujourd'hui à là encore dans cette
époque est celle d'une forme
d'autoritarisme gaulliste d'une forme de
mainmise sur l'information
que vous faites le président j'espère
que c'est bien enregistrer ce que vous
êtes en train d isère pour preuve
vis-à-vis des manuels macro est un aveu
incroyable vous comparez ces
interventions à celle de l'eau et f ce
que je vous dis simplement et qu'il faut
démocratiser notre système que sa part
arrivé mais que en tous les cas si on
peut constater une chose en revanche
c'est qu'il n'y a ni l'ia à la
possibilité pour le président de la
république de s'exprimer effectivement
prioritairement vers les grands médias
mais cela n'empêche pas un certain
nombre de médias qui parfois
appartiennent eux à des groupes
financiers de mener des politiques de
communication très agressive envers le
pouvoir politique il m'arrive de
regarder ses news il parie mme d'écouté
europe 1 on ne peut pas dire que ma
famille politique il soit
particulièrement bien traité et ben vous
voyez monsieur
c'est peut-être la différence entre vous
et moi moi je préfère que des chaînes
financées par des capitaux privés et
leur propre opinion que ce soit l'impôt
des français le vôtre est le mien qui
finance des opinions qui ne sont
absolument pas s'il voulait neutre quand
je vois ce qui se passe sur les chaînes
du service public parfois avec une
orientation et une ligne politique qui
est extrêmement clair soit en faveur du
gouvernement soit on éclaire sur une
ligne plutôt de gauche je préfère des
gens qui se paye potentiellement une
ligne politique que des gens qui font
payer sa part les contribuables oui ça
c'est certain c'est une divergence entre
nous une réponse peut-être
ya pas il n'y a pas la vérité l'ajout
fait une vraie réponse de centristes n'y
a pas de 2,2 méthode parfaite oui les
journées du service public sont
majoritairement à gauche
monsieur zemmour vous y mettre de
l'ordre alors comment fait il fait rival
et épurée je vous rappelle qu'il ya
d'autres chaînes ou si l'on ose se
moquer de monsieur pro est licencié le
lendemain alors si vous voulez le
problème c'est que quand vous êtes dans
une société privée vous devez respecter
la ligne officielle non vous étudierez
quand vous êtes dans une société
publique l'impôt des français sert
majoritairement effectivement à financer
une ligne qui est assez marquée à gauche
et nous les centristes les démocrates et
les modérés trouvons particulièrement
peu à nous exprimer nous aimer c'est que
c'est plus que le centrisme n'est pas du
tout accepté la télévision française
accepte on
va dire vous inviter à ces avec nos
impasses